in this film your character has slightly
more dramatic meat than it's had perhaps
in the other Marvel films there perhaps
be a bit more to do like the humor that
you bring whereas for mezcla more
serious tone into your performance and
wondered how that gets your experience
when we're not T in this felt
particularly compared to others um I
approach you all of it you know the same
way you show up you look at the
relationships what's going on
take it all seriously and still have as
much fun as you can on the inside of it
I'm really glad that we saw more of Nick
and what happens with him and you know
how he reacts to situations but as usual
you know he's always trying to be three
steps ahead and all of a sudden when he
finds out you know he's been used in
another kind of way and coming upon him
to find out why and use all the tools
that he has at his disposal to make that
happen
and as usual part of it has to do with
subterfuge and and diversion even down
to bully and hurting his most trusted
compete reott and we actually shot a
scene where that's explained or we have
that moment but I've been told it slows
the film down in a significant way and I
didn't want to slow down but when you
get the DVD and you click on my face
there's a hidden feature that will allow
you to access that scene and you'll see
more of what that means between he and
Black Widow but it was a real joy to be
able to go into Nick's workplace and to
find out who he is and depth in certain
ways and to expose some of the stuff
through the conversations that are
Robert Redford and I had in the film
Anthony and Joe as Destroyers are a lot
of stuff in the cutting room floor can
we expect a lot of extra scenes in the
DVD and blu-ray we we actually were
fortunate to have a lot of time to work
on the script and prep the movie
prior to execution so think I think it's
about six or seven minutes of deleted
scenes okay not not not a particularly
large amount
you